thanks Stella I I hear your question in
resonance say with Ryan's question also
about people who are involved in in the
area of the coal mining and how do they
factor into these types of issues of
environmental concern and the type of
response that now if I mentioned that
I've oh that's where I want to go yeah I
lost it when I was trying to connect
with Ryan's question my feeling is the
multiple multiple goods it's not a
matter of positioning those who are
extracting as bad evil villainous and
those who are resisting as the good guys
white hats
I think it's multiple goods across the
eye I think in the in the Western
context and I would say something
similar statements could be made in
South Asia Pacific East Asia in the
Americas Eurasia but in in the Americas
in I feel the what true what the drive
is in acquiring these multiple Goods
what what has motivated our relationship
with the natural world obviously a
number of issues but one that strikes me
as very interesting is our technological
drive we can do it we have to do it and
we can build the bigger machines to
remove the tar sands and they have been
built in China they are now in Vancouver
they are moving towards Idaho and the
request has been put to the state
government of Montana to literally Drive
these machines which are twice as wide
as this room and three times as high to
drive them up highway 12 to get to
Alberta we can make them we will make
them we must wait in this kind of
technological drive ask myself wearable
this come from or what what is this in
the human spirit and I I
I keep feeling a resonance back to the
apocalyptic
Malathi millennium as its described in
John's revelation or The Book of
Apocalypse they the sense of a thousand
year period in which the human will
achieve its dreams our dreams are the
the sense of a perfected world and that
millennial drive I feel is deeply
embedded in our technological world and
that along with that is a rage a rage in
the West against the human condition
that we will not tolerate the limits
that we encounter and so these multiple
goods that I see in these perspectives
they're motivated by sometimes or at
least I'm study religion so I'm
interested in tracing back those kinds
of motivations I feel those Goods have
very deep spiritual motivations so to
characterize them as good or bad I think
think sometimes misses it
what does strike me important though is
that we come out of a shared emergence
in this cosmos we we literally are the
journey of this universe insofar as we
realize that on this planet Earth we
have inherited something from our past
and we will hand it on to generations
after us and what we will hand on the
world that we will hand on is
significantly shaped by what we do to it
and that it is the earth community and
that's to me a criteria that's the
ethical that's a basis for ethical
regard and these really in these
engagement how do we begin to think
about the multiple Goods and the
multiple ethical voices I don't think
there is a global ethic in this regard
earth Charter is one example but even in
Earth Charter there restrain pushing
very hard to emphasize diversity
difference